اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بريانسكا الروسيه
المتاخمه للحدود الاوكرانيه
عن مقتل مدني واصابه طفل بجروح في اطلاق
للرصاص نفذته ما وصفها بمجموعه تخريبيه
اوكرانيه تسللت الى المقاطعه واكدت وسائل
اعلام روسيه ان نحو 50 مسلحا اوكرانيا
تسللوا الى الاراضي الروسيه ودخلوا مقاطعه
بريانز وان المجموعه المسلحه تحتجز اكثر
من 100 شخص
رهاء داخل منازل في مقاطعه بريانس من جهه
افادت الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه ان قواتها
المسلحه تشتبك مع المجموعه الاوكرانيه في
برياسك
معنى من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا دريد
رانيا
هل اتضح الموقف بشكل
جلي اكثر ما الذي يحصل في مقاطعه بيريانس
بالتحديد
يعني حتى هذه اللحظه حسن يعني هناك انباء
كثيره وهذه الانباء متضاربه كل ما تم
الاعلان عنه حتى هذه اللحظه رسميا وهو ان
هناك حاليا اشتباكات ما بين القوات
المسلحه الروسيه مع المجموعه التقريبيه
التي المتسلله
وصفاها جهاز امن الدوله انها مجموعه من
القوميين الاوكرانيين الذين تسللوا الى
داخل مقاطعه برانس فضلا عن ذلك يعني هناك
تصريحات كان قد ادلى بها حاكم المقاطعه
الذي الذي اكد ان هذه المجموعه قامت
باطلاق النار على احدى السيارات متى سببه
بمقتل مدنيا واصابه الطفل بجروح ولكن وفقا
للتصريحات يعني غير الرسميه منها ما هو
صادر عن وزاره الطوارئ الروسيه التي اشارت
الى ان هناك احتجاز لسته رهائن في احد
المحال التجاريه التجاريه في قريه سوشان
هذه القريه ايضا هناك انباء وسائل روسيه
تتحدث عن ان هذه المجموعه التخريبيه حاليا
قامت بالدخول لعدد من المنازل السكنيه هذه
القريه وادي الاشاره لانها لانه يقطنها
نحو 180 شخص وحتى هذه اللحظه من غير
الواضح عدد الرهائن المحتجزين في داخل
المباني السكنيه التي دخلها من تسميهم
موسكو بالقومين الاوكرانيين هذا من جهه من
جهه اخرى هناك ايضا وسائل اعلام روسيه
اخرى تتحدث وهذه الوسائل فعليا هي وسائل
عسكريه مطلعه تتحدث عن ان عدد القوميين
الاوكرانيين الذين نتسلل صباح اليوم الى
داخل مقاطعه برانس وهو يتواجدون في قريه
سوشان يبلغ عددهم نحو 50 شخصا وكل ما هو
مؤكد حتى هذه اللحظه هو ان هناك عمليات
عسكريه دائره في هذه المنطقه هناك يعني
تطويق لهذه القريه وحتى هذه اللحظه من غير
الواضح ماذا يجري على وجه التحديد في
الداخل ولكن وفقا لكل هذه الانباء حسن
يمكن القول ان هناك يعني احداث في غايه
الاهميه اهداف يعني احداث خطيره تجري
لاسيما وان الحديث يدور في بعض وسائل
الاعلام عن احتجاز العشرات من الرهائن في
داخل
المنازل في هذه القريه بالاضافه الى
احتجاز
رهائن في داخل متجر ايضا يتواجد في هذه
القريه